I'm truly glad to be able to come to you today
and give you just an overview of some good
news about the virus, and of course we'll
discuss the continued challenges. And there's
lots of bad news. So I'm not pretending it
doesn't exist, but I want to give everybody
some updates that will give us some hope that
we're starting to move in the right direction,
despite the obvious challenges and an unconscionable
death that still are ahead of us. So first
of all, the I H M E model, which is one of
the top models currently being monitored and
updated daily, has moved the peak in terms
of deaths in the United States up from April
16th to April 12th. That's now just four days
away. The peak day previously was expected
to have 3000 deaths in one day in the United
States. That number has dropped by almost
a third to twenty two hundred. Still horrifying.
But one third lower than it was expected to
be. Now, importantly, the peak is not really
a single day. It's more of a plateau. And
that plateau is expected to run from today.
We are essentially in that peak plateau right
now from today until close to the end of the
month. But the latest prediction is that deaths
will start to decline in the United States
just four days from now. Roughly the peak
is going to come on a different day in different
states, California, New York, Massachusetts,
other places. But that is in general good
news. We are closer to getting over the hump
than we previously believed. Number two, another
bit of good news. Once the data from the last
few days was added to the model, the expected
death toll of this first wave of Corona virus
has dropped to 60000. Now, that's a crazy
number of people. But last week, the model
predicted 93000 deaths in the first wave in
the U.S. Earlier this week, the model predicted
82000. That number has now dropped an additional
sort of 27 ish percent to sixty thousand deaths,
a terrible number, but a reduction of almost
50 percent since the or 35 ish, 35, 40 percent
since the prediction was 93000. Now, why do
I keep saying the first wave really important
to understand this. Some models have a death
toll prediction. That is for what are expected
to be three waves of infection. This model
is looking just that, the first wave right
now, doctors and scientists believe we are
currently in wave one. We will fall off of
that wave in May, June, July in the fall.
There will be another peak, which is wave
two. And then in 2021, there would be a third
wave, which is wave three. Hopefully by then
we would be well-prepared to really mitigate,
but that remains to be seen. This wave may
end up with a far lower death toll than we
thought, which would be because of what we
are doing. I'll get to that in a moment. One
other bit of good news. AV, again, I told
you about AV again weeks ago, maybe a month
ago. It's one of the possible treatments that's
being explored for Corona virus. We are now
starting a clinical trial of Afghan Japanese
drug right here in Boston. Trump won't stop
talking about chloroquine. Chloroquine has
some promise, but recent studies are not super
auspicious. I previously told you about AB
again, it is showing promise and it's going
to be tested in Boston across a few hospitals.
Another bit of really good news is that New
York hospitals have been starting to discharge
more patients than are being that then are
having intakes that are being brought in over
the last few days. New York is a huge hotspot
right now. 35 percent of all official cases
in the country are in New York State. If you
include New Jersey, New York, New Jersey have
47 percent of all of the official cases. It's
a very good sign that things are starting
to level out there. Other states have to keep
it up in terms of distancing. Now, remember,
anytime that things look better than expected,
a whole bunch of people will say, we told
you you were overreacting. We can stop the
social distancing. This is a virus. It spreads
virally. That's where the word comes from.
If what you are doing works, it should feel
like you overreacted. If you're doing the
right thing, it should feel like you're doing
too much for the level of spread because you
have to be ahead of the curve. Anti-vaxxers
will often say we don't really need vaccines
because measles is so rare. A lot of these
conditions are so rare. They are rare because
of the success of the vaccines. If we reduce
deaths, as the model suggests we are doing,
it's because we were staying home and closing
things down, not despite it. It's still going
to be tough. We currently. About 13000 deaths
in the U.S., if we believe the model and we
will end up somewhere just under 61000, what
that means is that 80 percent of the death
is ahead of us, mostly in the next four to
six weeks. This is really tough. Let's stay
in this. Keep pushing on treatment. Keep moving
the vaccine forward. Keep being responsible.
And by the end of the week, I'll be able to
further update you about where the numbers
are.